I'm not your prisoner I'm here to
negotiate we have no problem killing
your son I dare you to go after
TR who said anything about
Charles all these years you wor hiding
someone
else I without family is head of the
Jade
dragons so we're like
criminals you could have told me that we
were trying to keep you safe yeah nice
work the family is under attack some new
gang wants to take our place it's time
for my brother to step up I don't want
to be a gangster what if I just want to
do what I want we have a word for the
entire one
[Music]
American our enemies are coming after
you to get to me starting to think that
neither of us really know Mom at all no
question
her I am still your mother tell me what
I want to know or I'm going to tattoo a
penis I mean face
okay hey hey hey
you go girl get what's yours or or don't
go girl or at least pause
girl which brother are you the killer
with for the dip
take action and end
this
I don't think we've ever hugged before
they're probably going to die
so might as well get one in before you
[Music]
go on Masterpiece we are vet whatever
happens the animal must come first we'll
finally of a new assistant from London
he went last May I begin Mr
har thought that went rather well James
look at the little faces you said we'd
wait just not sure what we're waiting
for if this Wars taught us anything to
cherish every
moment all creatures great and small on
[Music]
Masterpiece
Maya I see everything that you
are I always
[Music]
have don't be
afraid
you have so much pain in you you
you somewhat
rage that you can't contain
[Music]
it
you and
I are the
same
[Music]
so who's the
monster hey
Johnny how bad is school going to suck
you're not going to like it how bad well
it's like getting your nut smashed
together so hard they become just one
nut holy
you should be going to school every
day with John no thanks you might have
fun no I would not have fun I gu the
house when you guys are
[Music]
out what happened to the TV it was an
accident you're going to school and
you're going to grow a brain oh
come
on I hey DG you bringing your dolls to
school it's the '90s times are
changing sexual education let's start
with masturbation if you're going to
assign homework Johnny already did it
this morning shut the up dude
I haven't smoked I haven't had sex I
haven't had a girlfriend I'm going to
lose it you and me have been best
friends like our whole lives we're about
to get high for the first time can we
have drugs please let's do this
[Music]
right
oh can you guys believe we like having
an experience and experience in reality
is there a gas leak or something
nice costume Fu face it's possible that
the two of you might not be total
screw-ups take a long look this is what
life is holy Teddy I'm the last
virgin in school we can fix this we got
to find a fire fresh penis get your
fresh penis here Jesus Christ still has
that new penis smell you shut up all
right I'm just trying to
[Music]
help
what happened in the last case you were
with
Naro that was
good so it
[Music]
wasn't they were too late there was
nothing we could
[Music]
do I'm working on this new case a
missing scientist found on the edge of
the villages frozen
solid
what do you want it's been 6 years why
are you here because you both know what
really
happened and you need my
help I've seen that
before years
ago fine I'm just going to do this one
thing work together to close this case
and that's it for the two of us it is so
you want in
what burnt eyeballs self-inflicted
wounds
those men died before they
froze what the get out of here now you
okay she's not good with people she
cares
about what are we missing here with
someone out there on the ice
window the night country it takes us
one by one this isn't going to be
good I'm thinking stuff
bad
stuff I
know I feel
too I guess you're
thinking the worst part is
done it's
not finish what you
[Music]
started
the we all have
secrets I've realized that
[Music]
now who is that girl her name is claraa
dun would you care to ride with with me
W done
yes CL I haven't always found life easy
what do you mean I've sometimes felt
myself
betrayed is my brother at home I read
the announcement of his
marriage how strange that we haven't met
my sister is claraa
done this is very difficult I'm not sure
how much she's told
you some things are better left well
alone I don't know how you can bear it
you know nothing of what he's had to
deal with
[Music]
you watch The Poisoned in her ears no I
didn't you asked me to trust you and
this is what you do I'm trying to
help forgive me we will have
secrets for the last 3 years grelo
Blanco has owned Miami Distributing
cocaine Miss Miss bango's operation has
been efficient
deadly and Incredibly
successful let's get to
work there's a lot of women who leave
the man but not the life I
swear I know what I'm
doing
[Music]
can i s you a kilo this woman I want to
cut her head
off I'm going to tell every dealer in
Miami not to to touch you little
cook this is what that life does you
convince yourself a little more money a
little more juice then people get
hurt one woman is behind all this pull
the right card the whole house comes
down after all that I have been through
I'm not going to give it away for
nothing
[Music]
fore
spee come on
[Applause]
[Music]
so you right
me my girl worth riding to is hard to
[Music]
find not if you know where to look I'll
miss you every
second major e you were the first pilot
assigned to the 100ths me and bu clev
you are in charge of 35 planes and 350
air
crewmen don't you die on me before I get
over
there something big is brewing the E
will be sending up the largest air alada
ever assembled in the history of mankind
straight into Hitler's
territory and in complete and total air
superiority that's the
you might be the last pretty face I ever
[Music]
see what's the
move we lead our poor
Thro all that we do
day in day out does something to a guy
doesn't it we here to fight the monsters
the things these people are capable of
they got it coming trust
me Lord guard and guide The Men Who fly
through the great spaces of the sky are
we tusy men or what sir yes sir be with
them traversing the air in darkening
storms
or Sunshine fair I think we may be done
we are going to sit here and take it
we're going to stick with our mission as
long as we can
fly we won't go without a
[Music]
fight I just sometimes want to be
alone where I'm not somebody's wife not
somebody's
mother or I'm not defined by
tragedy don't you ever miss it
home I like our life
here the help the drivers makes
everything
easier as he's family you know you
always say that right you're her
employer not her friend
[Music]
now Hong Kong was supposed to be a fresh
start for me a fresh start really at
24 I think my marriage is over has David
been home no ma'am what am I still doing
here do you ever imagine yourself living
a completely different
[Music]
life go grab it you don't
you're just watching them every second
even when your eyes are closed and I
have no idea how it
happened no one should ever have to go
through what you're going
through I think we need to think about
getting out of here cuz we're drowning
and you don't see it the minute our feet
leave Hong Kong's soil we are abandoning
our
son why is she
[Music]
here not a moment goes by where I'm not
thinking about what I've
done people like me do they ever move
on
you're not betraying anyone by trying to
live a better
life we all need to keep
[Music]
living even
you we made New York the capital of the
world sex money betrayal we've all done
some awful things to each
[Music]
other that perfume she wears too much
for a woman with her face God we hated
each other it hurts terribly when a
great friendship Is Lost she was always
so jealous what kind of Predator does
this grotesque little Affair awfully fat
she's been a little nutty since the
divorce so poisonous you're no good
you're no good you're no good baby I'm
it again you're no good you're no good
you're no good baby you're no
[Music]
good